what do you think Letty I think I'm  loving Cuba right now wherever you go  how's it honeymoon going dawn what do  you want you're gonna work for me  dominic toretto just went rogue you  gonna turn your back on family I don't  know what she's got on him that wasn't  done I'm taking you down so write out  where I got  [Music]  you love me and you are not gonna shoot  me  this is kind of papers dominic toretto  just went rogue you gonna turn your back  on family  I'm taking you down so write out wanna  play like that  if you gotta catch da you're gonna need  a little help you want to tell me why  you just put me in a room with this  criminal you know I'm saying that tight  t-shirts cut off the circulation he'll  Brian you should get the disguise you  guys are gonna work together just don't  give up today  Oh  swimming or got you rolling  you